want to do a quick clarification on the
video on alcohols in one of in that
video I gave this example of this
alcohol right over here it has a triple
bond between the five and six carbons
and I just want to clarify that in
reality it would not ever be drawn this
way this was an error to actually draw
it this way the way I should have drawn
it is this right over here and you see
the only difference between these two
pictures starting with the 1 carbon two
carbon three carbon everything looks the
same for carbon attached to the hydroxyl
group everything looks the same and then
we get to the five carbon but instead of
bending back up we just keep going
straight to the six carbon that's where
we have the triple bond between the five
and six carbon and then we go straight
again to the seven carbon that's
attached to the two bromo group so then
we get to the eighth carbon and the
whole point why this right over here
that this is the correct way to draw it
the correct way to draw it is that
triple bonds this triple bond right here
it forces a linear configuration so on
both sides of that triple bond you would
go straight out so whenever you see an
out well actually whenever you see any
type of an alkyne drawn the triple bonds
should essentially straighten out it
should straighten out the molecule